With most of us still following shelter-in-place rules, getting mental health care for those among us who need it can be a challenge. You're probably very familiar with the act of going to the office of a practitioner to engage in psychotherapy, but that's not an option now, both for patient safety and for the safety of the practitioner. Fortunately, many psychological practitioners have been offering telemental health services for years, and by telemental health, I mean using electronic and telecommunications technologies to engage in psychotherapy virtually or by phone. The COVID-19 pandemic has led to many recent changes in the laws and state regulations governing telemental health care. But what are the rules where you live? How do you get set up with a provider to receive therapy virtually? How do you know if your insurance
由于我们大多数人仍在遵守居家令，对于那些需要心理健康护理的人来说，获得相关服务可能是一个挑战。你可能非常熟悉前往诊所进行心理治疗的做法，但现在这已不再是一个可行的选择，无论是为了患者的安全还是从业者的安全。幸运的是，许多心理学从业者多年来一直提供远程心理健康服务。我所说的远程心理健康，是指利用电子和电信技术，通过虚拟方式或电话进行心理治疗。COVID-19疫情导致近期在管理远程心理健康护理的法律和州法规方面发生了许多变化。但你所在的地方有哪些规定？你如何与提供者建立联系以进行虚拟治疗？你如何知道你的保险
will pay for it? And is telemental health care as effective as face-to-face psychotherapy? These are some of the questions we will explore today on Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Joining me today to walk us through the ins and outs of telemental health is Dr. Jared Skillings, chief of professional practice for the American Psychological Association. Dr. Skillings leads the association's efforts to promote the practice of psychology and advocates for practicing psychologists through federal and state legislation, legal and regulatory initiatives, and public education. Before joining APA in 2018, Dr. Skillings held leadership positions within large group practice settings and complex integrated health systems.
是否会支付相关费用？远程心理健康护理是否与面对面的心理治疗一样有效？这些是我们今天将在美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）中探讨的一些问题。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天加入我，带我们了解远程心理健康方方面面的是美国心理学会专业实践主管杰瑞德·斯基林斯（Dr. Jared Skillings）博士。斯基林斯博士领导该协会推广心理学实践的工作，并通过联邦和州立法、法律和监管倡议以及公众教育为执业心理学家提供支持。在2018年加入美国心理学会之前，斯基林斯博士曾在大型团体执业环境和复杂的综合医疗系统中担任领导职务。
Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Skillings. My pleasure. Really glad to be here, Kim. My first and probably an obvious question is this. The COVID-19 pandemic is causing people quite a bit of stress and anxiety. And some folks could probably use professional help but don't have a mental health provider. How should these people go about finding one? Where do they start? Yeah, it's really important to know how to access services when you need to.
感谢您今天加入我们，斯基林斯博士。不客气，金，很高兴来到这里。我的第一个问题，可能也是一个显而易见的问题：COVID-19疫情正在给人们带来相当大的压力和焦虑。有些人可能需要专业帮助，但却没有心理健康提供者。这些人应该如何寻找？他们从哪里开始？是的，了解在需要时如何获得服务非常重要。
there's a couple of places that you should turn first. One of the things I would suggest is to consider talking to your primary care doctor. Even if you don't feel comfortable going to them in person, a number of them are offering telehealth visits. And so doing a mental health wellness checkup with your primary care doctor through the computer, they could give you some initial ideas about how you're coping and then make a referral to a mental health specialist if needed. Another option, if you have, for example, a known history of having a mental illness or diagnosis where you've been treated before, is you could actually go to your insurance company online and to look at what providers are available and find a psychologist who would be available to take patients in person or probably during the coronavirus crisis, preferably in telehealth as well. How can people check that a mental health provider is qualified or can handle the particular problem that a person has? You really want to make sure you find someone who knows what they're doing.
首先你应该求助于几个地方。我建议的一件事是考虑与你的初级保健医生交谈。即使你觉得不方便亲自去看他们，他们中也有许多人提供远程医疗访问。因此，通过电脑与你的初级保健医生进行心理健康检查，他们可以为你提供一些关于你如何应对的初步建议，并在需要时转介给心理健康专家。另一个选择是，如果你有已知的心理疾病史或曾接受过治疗的诊断，你可以直接在网上查看你的保险公司，看看有哪些提供者，并找到一位可以在疫情期间亲自或（更推荐）通过远程医疗接诊的心理学家。人们如何核实心理健康提供者是否合格，或者能否处理他们特定的问题？你确实需要确保找到一个专业的人。
just like you wouldn't send your mother to get a surgery to a surgeon that is not licensed, you don't want to do that with mental health issues either. What I suggest is you want to look up in the state where you're at to double check that your provider is licensed. That's an easy way to do that. What you want to do is go to Google and you can type in health license lookup or psychology license look up and then put your state. Missouri, Nebraska, et cetera. And what that will do is that will take you to the Board of Psychology
就像你不会让你的母亲去找一个没有执照的外科医生做手术一样，你也不想在心理健康问题上这样做。我的建议是，你应该在你所在的州查询，以核实你的提供者是否拥有执照。这是一个简单的方法。你可以在谷歌上搜索“健康执照查询”或“心理学执照查询”，然后加上你所在的州，比如密苏里州、内布拉斯加州等。这样做会带你进入心理学委员会的
webpage where they keep track of everybody who's licensed. And just for folks to know, licensure is the minimal requirements to practice psychology and a number of other professions like counseling and social work. And what about your insurance company? Can they provide guidance as well? They can. Insurance companies will not credential your psychologist if they don't have a license. So if your insurance company suggests that you go see Dr. Jones, you can be assured that Dr. Jones, in fact, will have a license. One of the things that would be helpful during this crisis is there are a lot of people who are non-licensed, who are offering services that are coaching or other kind of encouragement. And that might be okay in some settings and some ways. But when you really want to get an evaluation, you have to make sure that your person is licensed.
网页，他们会记录所有拥有执照的人。顺便让大家知道，执照是从事心理学以及咨询和社会工作等许多其他职业的最低要求。那么你的保险公司呢？他们能提供指导吗？他们可以。如果你的心理学家没有执照，保险公司是不会为其提供认证的。所以，如果你的保险公司建议你去看琼斯医生，你可以确信琼斯医生确实拥有执照。在这次危机中，有一点很有帮助，那就是有很多人没有执照，却在提供辅导或其他形式的鼓励服务。这在某些情况下可能没问题，但当你真正需要评估时，你必须确保为你服务的人拥有执照。
I would even recommend that you should check in to see whether they're board certified as well. What does that mean board certified? Board certified in psychology is advanced competence. So let me give you an example. So we've heard about an increase in trauma significantly during the coronavirus crisis, as well as difficulties with sleeping and eating. There are specializations in some of those areas. And so if you have a board certified psychologist, that proves not just that they have a general ability to
我甚至建议你检查一下他们是否获得了委员会认证。什么是委员会认证？心理学的委员会认证代表了高级能力。让我举个例子。我们听说在新冠疫情期间，创伤显著增加，睡眠和饮食方面也出现了困难。在这些领域中有专门的专业化。因此，如果你有一位获得委员会认证的心理学家，这不仅证明他们有一般的能力来
practice, but they have a real specialization in an area and their peers and standards have been met, their peers have evaluated them to make sure they have met the standards to be able to practice that specialty. So how does telehealth work exactly? Do you just meet up with a psychologist on FaceTime or Zoom? Well, I wouldn't suggest just meeting up with somebody. You don't want to just meet with somebody like a Facebook. Not a random person. I mean, once you get a referral. Good. No, no, don't do that. What you do want to do, however, once you find a provider who's a good fit for the kind of services that you need, it is a little bit like just meeting up in an office.
执业，还证明他们在某个领域有真正的专业化，并且他们的同行和标准已经得到满足，他们的同行已经评估过他们，以确保他们达到了能够执业该专业的标准。那么远程医疗到底是如何运作的？你只是在FaceTime或Zoom上与心理学家见面吗？嗯，我不建议只是随便找个人见面。你不想像在Facebook上那样随便找个人。不是随便的人。我是说，一旦你得到了转介。好的。不，不，不要那样做。然而，一旦你找到了一个适合你所需服务类型的提供者，这确实有点像在办公室见面。
And in fact, what you'll do is you'll make an agreement that the psychologist will pick the kind of platform you want to use. For example, there's some of them that are compliant with HIPAA. HIPAA is a whole big law that was passed by the federal government years ago that was supposed to protect. and does when it works well, protect patient privacy. So the psychologist will choose a telehealth platform. You mentioned a couple of very common ones. Skype, FaceTime, there's a whole bunch of other ones that are even more protective of the patient's private information. And so the psychologist will pick one of those and then send you information about how to log in.
事实上，你会达成一个协议，由心理学家选择你想要使用的平台。例如，有些平台符合HIPAA标准。HIPAA是联邦政府多年前通过的一项大型法律，旨在保护——并且在运作良好时确实能保护——患者的隐私。因此，心理学家会选择一个远程医疗平台。你提到了几个非常常见的平台：Skype、FaceTime，还有很多其他甚至更能保护患者私人信息的平台。心理学家会选择其中一个，然后发送给你关于如何登录的信息。
So that way, it's like showing up for an appointment in the office. You'll log in five minutes early. You'll make sure that it works and that your microphone's working. And then when the session's about to start, the psychologist will come on and walk you through the process. Psychologists often keep notes when they're working with people. Do they keep these recordings? Do you know? Not unless you agree on it. There's a whole range of options for that.
这样，就像去办公室预约一样。你会提前五分钟登录。你会确保它能正常工作，并且你的麦克风也能正常工作。然后当疗程即将开始时，心理学家会出现并引导你完成整个过程。心理学家在与人工作时经常会做笔记。他们会保留这些录音吗？你知道吗？除非你同意。这有一系列的选择。
I know of patients, let me go back to the trauma example for a minute. When I was seeing patients, I had some patients who had a previous history of trauma when they were working through developing coping skills that they they would ask to record parts of this session with like a handheld recorder. This probably shows my age. I was going to say cassette recorder. So they would bring it in and they would just push record and record parts of it. That's possible to do through even easier through telehealth, but you have to make sure that both parties are in agreement. I'm not a lawyer, but I know there are state laws that vary from state to state about whether that's okay and when.
我知道有些患者，让我回到刚才的创伤例子。当我还在看诊时，我有一些曾有创伤史的患者，当他们在努力培养应对技能时，他们会要求用手持录音机录下疗程的部分内容。这可能暴露了我的年龄。我本来想说卡式录音机。所以他们会带进来，按下录音键，录下部分内容。通过远程医疗更容易做到这一点，但你必须确保双方都同意。我不是律师，但我知道各州关于这是否可以以及何时可以的法律各不相同。
So you have to make sure that you both agree on it. But that is possible. What about people who are over 65 and have Medicare as their insurance? Does Medicare cover these kinds of sessions? Medicare does cover these kinds of sessions. And in fact, they have done a terrific job of providing access. One of the things we know about the coronavirus is that folks who are older adults are at a higher risk. And so we have specifically recommended that they consider telehealth options for psychology during the crisis. Just so the public, so folks listening to this podcast will be aware, the good thing that Medicare is not only have they approved telehealth or video conferencing options, but they have approved
所以你必须确保你们双方都同意。但这是可能的。那么对于65岁以上并拥有联邦医疗保险（Medicare）的人呢？Medicare涵盖这类疗程吗？Medicare确实涵盖这类疗程。事实上，他们在提供获取途径方面做得非常出色。关于新冠病毒，我们知道的一件事是老年人面临更高的风险。因此，我们特别建议他们在危机期间考虑心理学的远程医疗选项。为了让公众，也就是听这个播客的人了解，Medicare的好处不仅在于他们批准了远程医疗或视频会议选项，而且他们还批准了
phone-only services. So that, for example, if you don't have a computer or an iPad that will work very effectively, or you're not really comfortable with that, your psychologist can work with you just through the telephone and be able to provide high-quality services that way. Is psychotherapy via the internet as effective as traditional face-to-face psychotherapy? The research is admittedly a little more limited because, to be honest, before the coronavirus, there were some practices that we're using telehealth, but that was definitely not the norm. Most people were still providing services, medical services and mental health services, in a normal in-person office. So we do have research, and the research that we do have, although it's kind of limited, shows that it really meant mental health services delivered through telehealth or in person. You get the same benefit from both. They both will really work well. I know there's research into psychotherapy that all kinds of psychotherapy can be effective. There's research into that, right?
仅限电话的服务。因此，例如，如果你没有电脑或iPad，或者你对使用这些设备不太习惯，你的心理学家可以通过电话与你合作，并以这种方式提供高质量的服务。通过互联网进行心理治疗是否与传统的面对面心理治疗一样有效？研究确实比较有限，因为老实说，在新冠病毒出现之前，虽然有一些诊所在使用远程医疗，但这绝对不是常态。大多数人仍然在正常的办公室里提供医疗服务和心理健康服务。所以我们确实有研究，虽然研究比较有限，但它表明，无论是通过远程医疗还是面对面提供的心理健康服务，你都能从两者中获得同样的益处。它们都能很好地发挥作用。我知道有关于心理治疗的研究，各种心理治疗都是有效的。有关于这方面的研究，对吧？
That's true. Across the board, one of the things that we know is that developing a therapeutic relationship with a psychologist who can guide you through some of the most difficult things in your life that you may talk about in a private psychotherapy session and helping the patient work through those issues in a system. way is overwhelmingly positive and helpful. That's right. What about people who don't have insurance? Is there a way for them to get this kind of care? That is one of the most difficult things to deal with right now is that the way our health system is structured is that most health insurance is set up through your job. So when people right now are losing their jobs or don't have access to health insurance. Because of that, it makes it impressively hard to keep up with their health needs, which is just really an awful tragedy. So there's a couple of options. One is that there's a lot right now during the coronavirus crisis of free services. There are help lines that you can call to be able to find where you can find pro bono or free services in your community. There's also a lot of mental health practitioners that are offering options through various community channels. so that you can join a group conversation about coping skills or managing your money or your time or your emotions, many of which are free.
没错。总的来说，我们知道的一件事是，与一位心理学家建立治疗关系，他们可以引导你度过生活中一些最困难的事情（你可能会在私下的心理治疗中谈论这些），并帮助患者以系统的方式解决这些问题，这是非常有益且积极的。确实如此。那么没有保险的人呢？他们有办法获得这种护理吗？这是目前最难处理的事情之一，因为我们的卫生系统结构是大多数健康保险都是通过你的工作设置的。所以当人们现在失去工作或无法获得健康保险时，这使得他们很难维持自己的健康需求，这真是一场可怕的悲剧。所以有几个选择。一个是目前在新冠疫情期间有很多免费服务。你可以拨打求助热线，找到你所在社区可以提供公益或免费服务的地方。还有许多心理健康从业者通过各种社区渠道提供选择，这样你就可以参加关于应对技能、管理金钱、时间或情绪的团体对话，其中许多是免费的。
I would offer one last suggestion, which is if you do have a job or if you may have just lost your job, a lot of, which is far too common these days, a lot of employers have an employee assistance program or an EAP, and you can often continue those kind of health benefits. fits for some period of time, even after you might have left your current job. And they do short-term treatment to try to get you through. There's a lot of publicity around mental health apps that you can download on your phone. Do they provide the same degree of help for people who are under stress or anxious? Mental health apps can be really helpful. I want to say that they probably don't provide the same kind or the same level of support. Mental health apps, I'm going to speak in real generalities, because there's a, huge different range of different kinds of apps. And some of them are really good. Some of them
我想提供最后一个建议，如果你有工作，或者你可能刚刚失业（这在今天太常见了），许多雇主都有员工援助计划（EAP），即使在你离开当前工作后，你通常也可以在一段时间内继续享受这些健康福利。他们会进行短期治疗，试图帮助你度过难关。现在有很多关于心理健康应用程序的宣传，你可以在手机上下载。它们能为处于压力或焦虑中的人提供同样程度的帮助吗？心理健康应用程序确实很有帮助。我想说的是，它们可能无法提供同样种类或同样水平的支持。心理健康应用程序，我将泛泛而谈，因为有各种各样不同类型的应用程序。其中一些真的很好。有些
are not. Some of them actually potentially could be harmful if you're not careful. So what I would suggest overall is that if you can find some good ones, what they'll do is they provide general information and some specific instructions that are tailored to the overall population. So if you have a pretty common concern, let me give an example that's unfortunately too common these days. If you have someone in your family who's passed away recently and you're struggling with grief and loss, that's a pretty common experience as part of the human condition. And so some of the, some of the apps, for example, will walk you through about how to recognize grief and loss symptoms and emotions, some ways to think and feel and behave differently. But again, that's a
则不然。如果你不小心，有些甚至可能是有害的。所以我总体的建议是，如果你能找到一些好的应用程序，它们会提供一般性的信息和一些针对大众的特定指导。所以如果你有一个相当普遍的担忧，让我举一个不幸在今天太常见的例子。如果你的家人最近去世了，你正在经历悲伤和失落，这是人类状况中相当普遍的经历。因此，一些应用程序会引导你了解如何识别悲伤和失落的症状和情绪，以及一些思考、感受和行为方式的改变。但同样，这是一种
pretty common experience. If you have a more unusual set of circumstances in your life or a more unusual set of symptoms, apps tend to be less helpful. And no matter whether your symptoms are more common or more rare, there's still always significant benefit of having a connection with another person who can hear your individual story, offer some empathy, and then guidance about what to do. I hear a lot of ads and promotions about these apps where you can text a professional at any time of the day or night and get help. Does that really work? Not really by itself. It's texting is a really helpful service in the context of a larger
相当普遍的经历。如果你的生活中有一套更不寻常的情况或更不寻常的症状，应用程序往往帮助较小。无论你的症状是更常见还是更罕见，与另一个人建立联系，让他们倾听你的个人故事、提供同理心，然后指导你该怎么做，这始终具有显著的益处。我听到很多关于这些应用程序的广告和促销，说你可以随时随地给专业人士发短信并获得帮助。这真的有效吗？单独使用并不真正有效。短信是在更广泛的
treatment. In fact, I'll say myself, I've used texting with patients who I have already been working with. So when you have a relationship, the psychologist has a relationship with the patient and you know each other and you know the issues, sending a quick text back and forth can be very helpful just to check in, offer some reassurance for the patient to check in, like I'll give you an example. So if you're working on depression symptoms, the patient might send a text every day of the week or a couple days a week to say what level their depression symptoms are at, or if there's an emergency and they need some help. Those are all great ways to use texting. One of the things that's going on right now is there are some apps that are allowing mental health
治疗背景下的一项非常有用的服务。事实上，我自己也曾与我已经合作过的患者使用过短信。所以当你有了这种关系，心理学家与患者建立了关系，你们互相了解，也了解问题所在，来回发送简短的短信可以非常有帮助，只是为了确认情况，提供一些安慰。我给你举个例子。如果你正在处理抑郁症状，患者可能会在一周内每天或几天发一条短信，说明他们的抑郁症状处于什么水平，或者如果发生紧急情况，他们需要一些帮助。这些都是使用短信的好方法。目前正在发生的一件事是，有一些应用程序允许心理健康
practitioners to work with people and the patients are anonymous. You don't have to identify yourself and while that might sound like a really interesting idea, like I could have totally, totally private therapy, it's really a huge risk because you don't know, you don't really know each other. And therefore, if something really awful happens, there isn't a way for the psychologist to try to help care for you or get you help in an emergency basis if they don't really know where you are or who you are. Yeah, where do you send the ambulance when somebody is in distress? That's a problem.
从业者与人们合作，而患者是匿名的。你不必表明身份，虽然这听起来可能是一个非常有趣的想法，比如我可以进行完全私密的治疗，但这实际上是一个巨大的风险，因为你们并不了解对方。因此，如果发生了非常糟糕的事情，如果心理学家真的不知道你在哪里或你是谁，他们就没有办法在紧急情况下帮助照顾你或为你寻求帮助。是的，当有人处于困境时，你把救护车送到哪里？这是一个问题。
That's precisely right. It is. It's really risky. And a lot of times people don't think about what happens in an emergency. but in this circumstance, that's part of our job here at APA to think about all the different situations. How should people choose a mental health app? Are they screened or rated by any kind of authoritative body?
完全正确。确实如此。这真的很冒险。很多时候人们不会考虑紧急情况下会发生什么，但在这种情况下，这就是我们美国心理学会（APA）在这里的工作的一部分，即考虑所有不同的情况。人们应该如何选择心理健康应用程序？它们是否经过任何权威机构的筛选或评级？
The best one that I'm aware of so far is called Cyber Guide. You can look that up online. They do a really good job, not just of reviewing the, whether the apps follow psychological science, but also the usability. What I would suggest is you have to be careful about the ratings, on, for example, the iTunes or Google Play Store, because really what that really tells you is how much people generally like it. Those kind of general ratings in public don't tell you whether or not the app is actually based in psychological science because there's a lot of things people
据我所知，目前最好的一个叫Cyber Guide。你可以在网上查一下。他们做得非常好，不仅审查应用程序是否遵循心理学科学，还审查其可用性。我的建议是，你必须小心iTunes或Google Play商店上的评级，因为那实际上告诉你的是人们普遍有多喜欢它。那种公众的一般评级并不能告诉你该应用程序是否真正基于心理学科学，因为有很多事情是人们
enjoy but have no scientific basis and may not actually help them help their symptoms get better. They may kind of feel good, but that's why I would suggest this other option called Cyber Guide. there are a lot of cases of students who had to go home when their schools stopped holding face-to-face sessions. And now they're back with their parents. So maybe you went to school in California and you had to go home to New Jersey. Can you see the therapist that you were seeing in California when you go back to New Jersey? What are the rules? That's a terrific example about college kids really struggling to find access to care.
喜欢的，但没有任何科学依据，实际上可能并不能帮助他们的症状好转。他们可能感觉良好，但这就是为什么我建议使用另一个名为Cyber Guide的选项。有很多学生在学校停止面对面授课时不得不回家。现在他们和父母在一起。所以也许你在加州上学，不得不回到新泽西州。当你回到新泽西州时，你能见你在加州见的那位治疗师吗？规则是什么？这是一个关于大学生确实难以获得护理的绝佳例子。
I think there's actually several other examples. I have heard of older adults who are sheltering in place with their kids. kids or family members doing that. So I think that's happening across the whole country. One of the things that's true about mental health services, just like medical services, is that your license is dependent on your state. So if you're licensed, I'm from Michigan. So I'm licensed in Michigan. I am not allowed, therefore, to see patients in a normal circumstance in Nebraska or Ohio. During this crisis, however, a number of states have loosened those restrictions to allow the example, Kim, that you just brought up. If a college student needs
我认为实际上还有其他几个例子。我听说过老年人与他们的孩子或家庭成员一起居家避疫。所以我认为这在全国范围内都在发生。关于心理健康服务，就像医疗服务一样，有一点是真实的，那就是你的执照取决于你所在的州。所以如果你有执照，我来自密歇根州。所以我是在密歇根州获得执照的。因此，在正常情况下，我不被允许在内布拉斯加州或俄亥俄州看病人。然而，在这次危机期间，一些州放宽了这些限制，以允许金你刚才提到的例子。如果一名大学生需要
access to their therapist, then hopefully, depending on the state law, they'd be able to continue to see them. This is, from my memory, I think it was only about half of the states, in fact, agreed to that. So some of them will allow it. Some of them will not. We'd like to see during the crisis for that to roll out over the whole country to provide better access to mental health care. So do you call your state health department to find out? How do you check? up on things like this. Yeah, where do you find out? The psychologists have been given resources that the APA developed so that they should know or have a way to know which states allow what. If you're in the public, the best thing to do is to simply just contact your mental health
获得他们治疗师的帮助，那么希望根据州法律，他们能够继续看他们。据我的记忆，实际上只有大约一半的州同意这一点。所以有些州会允许，有些则不会。我们希望在危机期间，这能在全国范围内推广，以提供更好的心理健康护理途径。那么你是否要打电话给你的州卫生部门来了解情况？你如何核实这类事情？是的，你在哪里了解？心理学家已经获得了美国心理学会开发的资源，所以他们应该知道或有办法知道哪些州允许什么。如果你是公众，最好的办法就是直接联系你的心理健康
provider to ask. If you've been seeing someone, let's use your example, Kim. If you're a college student in California and your therapist is in California, you should contact your therapist and ask them whether they continue to see you. That is really their job as a professional to know whether they can or cannot do that or to look that information up. What if you have a situation where you and the psychologists agree that medication would be helpful, but most psychologists aren't able to prescribe? How is that dealt with? True.
提供者来询问。如果你一直在看某人，让我们用你的例子，金。如果你是一名在加州的大学生，而你的治疗师在加州，你应该联系你的治疗师，询问他们是否可以继续看你。作为专业人士，了解他们是否可以这样做，或者查找该信息，确实是他们的工作。如果你和心理学家同意药物治疗会有帮助，但大多数心理学家不能开处方，这种情况该如何处理？确实。
There's a few states where psychologists can prescribe medications, but it's not very many. Normally, psychologists will partner with primary care doctors and or psychiatrists. These days, psychiatrists tend to focus on more serious or more specialized kinds of diagnoses. Primary care doctors will prescribe medication for a whole range of different mental health conditions and symptoms. And so it's much more common for psychologists to work with primary care. And that may be, in fact, a primary care physician or a nurse practitioner or physician assistant who is serving as a primary care provider as well. So if a patient needs medication or the psychologist and them decide that that's a good next step, then usually primary care is the first place you might turn just to get the most easy access. Wearing your practitioner hat now.
有少数几个州心理学家可以开处方药，但数量不多。通常，心理学家会与初级保健医生和/或精神科医生合作。这些天，精神科医生倾向于专注于更严重或更专业的诊断。初级保健医生会为各种不同的心理健康状况和症状开药。因此，心理学家与初级保健医生合作更为常见。事实上，这可能是一位初级保健医生、执业护士或医师助理，他们也担任初级保健提供者。所以如果患者需要药物，或者心理学家和他们决定这是好的下一步，那么通常初级保健是你可能首先求助的地方，以获得最容易的途径。现在戴上你的从业者帽子。
What kind of advice would you have for people who are feeling anxious as they try to deal with the pandemic? This is such a difficult time for people. There is – I appreciate you're bringing up anxiety. There's a lot of anxiety about what has already happened with the crisis, what's going to happen. So anticipatory anxiety. And it's not just anxiety, but a lot of grief and loss and anticipatory grief and loss, afraid that people have actually and will continue to lose loved ones, lose jobs or afraid of losing jobs or having income cut, not being able to provide for their families. what I would suggest is that I want people to know that they are not alone. Even though we are supposed to be socially isolating to try to flatten the curve, you have to make sure you remind yourself that we're doing that together as a country, as the whole world, and to try to reach out and get social support.
对于那些在试图应对疫情时感到焦虑的人，你有什么建议？这对人们来说是一个非常困难的时期。我很感激你提到了焦虑。对于危机中已经发生的事情、将要发生的事情，存在很多焦虑。所以是预期性焦虑。而且不仅仅是焦虑，还有很多悲伤和失落，以及预期性的悲伤和失落，害怕人们已经并将继续失去亲人、失去工作，或者害怕失去工作或收入减少，无法养家糊口。我的建议是，我希望人们知道他们并不孤单。尽管我们应该进行社会隔离以试图拉平曲线，但你必须确保提醒自己，我们作为一个国家，作为整个世界，正在共同努力，并尝试伸出援手获得社会支持。
People need to continue to have a rhythm and a routine to keep up. the things that keep them going. Make sure you're getting good sleep. Make sure you're eating healthy food. Try to get outside and exercise while staying six feet away. Those kind of general health suggestions and maintaining social supports and relationships so that you know you can just feel that there's support and that there are others in this with you.
人们需要继续保持节奏和常规来坚持下去。确保你有良好的睡眠。确保你吃健康的食物。尝试在保持六英尺距离的同时到户外锻炼。这些是一般的健康建议，并维持社会支持和关系，这样你就知道你可以感觉到有支持，并且还有其他人与你在一起。
That's really crucial right now. That was all really great advice. Thank you, Dr. Skillings. I really appreciate you joining us today. I know you're really busy, but this is all important information that I think our listeners are going to be able to use. Thanks so much. I just want to wish everyone well and hope that people stay healthy and stay connected to each other. Definitely.
这在目前非常关键。那真是非常好的建议。谢谢你，斯基林斯博士。我非常感谢你今天加入我们。我知道你真的很忙，但这些都是我认为我们的听众能够用得上的重要信息。非常感谢。我只想祝愿大家一切顺利，希望人们保持健康并保持彼此的联系。当然。
The American Psychological Association has many resources and tipsheets available on our website for help in navigating the pandemic. Visit us at APA.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org, and you can subscribe on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts, and please, while you're there, give us a rating. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org, that's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
美国心理学会的网站上有许多资源和提示单，可帮助应对疫情。请访问我们的网站APA.org。你也可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集，你可以在Apple、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方订阅，请在订阅时给我们评分。如果你有对未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org，即speaking of psychology，连在一起，在apa.org。感谢你的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。